were asking officials from the
Department of Education today how well
they think it's going in targeting their
support for schools for catch-up and
what the other wider issues are that
they're having to support children on a
particularly disadvantaged pupils as
they seek and we all seek we hope to see
a turbo charge of catch up to make sure
pupils are not left behind so I would
like very much to welcome our Witnesses
today we have Susan Atkinson of course
the permanent secretary at the
department Andrew McCully who's the
director general for the schools group
and Graham Archer who's the interim
director general for the strategy group
and um we understand recycling hood that
Mr Macaulay and Mr Archer are both
retiring after a very long period of
service at the department for education
and I wondered if you'd like to say a
few words thank you for giving me the
opportunity yes both Andrew and Graham
joined the Department uh actually at
roughly the same time and both of them
have been exemplary public servants who
have contributed enormously to Across
the work of the department Andrew most
recently has been the face of everything
the department has done on school's
policy for a number reviews and has been
responsible for a a huge part of the
Improvement in standards that we've seen
over particularly the 10 years up to the
pandemic and Graham has worked on both
schools and on children's social care
and indeed across a number of other
areas and the both of them will be
profoundly missed by colleagues across
the department who've welcomed their
wisdom and expertise
well thank you and Mr McCulley and Mr
Archer we want to thank you too and you
know you exemplify long
serious long Public Service aimed at
improving a lot of people in this
country I'm sure at all times you'll be
in front of committees like this where
we have criticized and challenged you on
that but we appreciate your
long-standing public service and what
you've contributed to this country so
thank you for that and that's the nice
bit
now we're going to challenge you in your
last two weeks and two months so I'm
sure you've girded your loins and you're
prepared for that but before we go into
the main session I just wanted to ask
him as accented we've obviously seen
increased disruption in our schools
because of strikes and when I've spoken
to teachers about this they're very
concerned they don't want to go on
strike they're just they can't afford to
live and particularly in constituencies
like mining in London and they're very
concerned about the impact of funding in
the classroom as one said it's coming
down to whether we can afford glue
sticks so I was wondering if you could
update us on the situation and whether
the department is getting around the
table with the unions to try and sort
this out and avert strike action and
support teachers and pupils thank you
chair certainly yes I hear the same
thing as you that most teachers don't
want to be on strike they want to be
teaching children and helping them to
succeed and we are absolutely committed
to getting around the table and sorting
this out we've made repeated offers to
the unions for substantive serious talks
on pay on exactly the same basis that
those offers of talks have been made to
the nurses and to the other health
unions who are now in negotiations uh
the one thing we've asked is that
strikes be suspended to allow those
talks to take place and unfortunately up
until this point the only you've not
been willing to suspend strikes in order
to come to the table so that's the
barrier at the moment have you put in
any preconditions uh no only literally
only that they suspense strikes in order
to come to table that's the only
precondition
um and have I mean this in the end this
has been going a long time government
didn't seek to have meetings with the
unions before Christmas so what's
changed actually this actually did offer
a meeting is just before Christmas I
mean as it happens we've been meeting
extensively through January and February
um and uh the the challenge then was
that we that the key matters we were
discussing were kind of non-pay and pay
for future years
and at that stage uh because we'd made a
quite significant payoff in the current
year we weren't talking about current
year paying we were talking about next
year's pay principally in the context of
the strb that that's changed now and
there's an offer to talk about pay uh in
all years and to have really substantive
conversations but as I say the one
precondition is that Strike should be
suspended to allow those talks to take
place I mean there's a bit of a Face-Off
here isn't it cutting off his nose to
spike Face seems to me um the phrase
that comes to mind I mean isn't it
better just to get on with those
discussions without a precondition in
order to make sure that you're just
making sure there's progress someone's
got to be the grown-up here both sides
have got very strong issues that we all
know from the evidence we've seen in
preparation for today alone we've just
reminded it's a reminder of the very big
challenges schools are facing with
finances including on pay
um why can't the government just get
around the table so the government's
ready to get around the table I mean but
only with a preconditional I'll leave
this meeting and go and have the talks
now if that if if if the unions are
willing to come to the table and have
those talks it's like chicken an egg if
you could have the discount conversation
then if it went well the strikes might
be called off I mean you know it's
there's no budging is what you're saying
it's exactly it's exactly the same uh
setup has been offered to the Royal
College of nurses to GMB to Unison and
uniting all of those unions of course
their strike action comes out exactly
the same basis that's being offered to
the Neu okay well it is not this
committee's job to have a negotiation
about this but it's helpful to have your
views on the record I'm sure that will
be picked up
um and on the issue of Staff um so
Jeffrey Clifton Brown yes good morning
everybody again may I add my sincere
thanks to Andrew McCully and Graham
Archer on their very long Service uh
it's uh it's a real Mark of the uh
expect that civil servants are held in
when they they hear about examples of
what you've done so thank you
um I want to ask Mr Clinton Hood about a
staff Recruitment and Retention now I've
talked to lots of teachers recently as
I'm sure everybody more or less in this
room has and the pressures they are on
particularly heads and deputies are
enormous and I'm particularly conscious
of the submission by education support
where they say most staff stated that
this added one to six additional hours
to their working week this is
significant issue where addition when we
consider in 2021 35 of all staff and 66
percent of senior leaders told us they
already worked 51 hours a week and they
say that in their
2022 teacher well-being index shows that
59 of staff are considered leaving the
sector in the past Academic Year and 30
of teachers reported that their
work-life balance was either bad or very
bad and more than one-third of teachers
said they're working between 10 and 25
hours outside the school day on average
I mean this is this is this is not a
great situation is it and I wonder what
the department can do irrespectively I
mean to clearly pay as one element of
this but working conditions is a also a
significant element what can the
department do to assist in this
so I think it's really important that we
um work with teachers on teacher
workload and that's the approach that
we've taken in the past as we've worked
to reduce teach work and then we saw it
make a real difference so we've got
um good figures from particularly from
before the pandemic
that show significant reductions in
teacher workload including the average
number of hours teachers were working
each week as a result of the measures
that we put in principally around making
sure that there were
um
really good bits of advice around
um necessary and unnecessary tasks
essentially
um there are quite a lot of things that
build up over time it's much easier to
decide you need to do a new thing than
to drop a thing that you've previously
done I'm actually going to ask Andrew to
talk about this because he worked
extensively on the on the workload
compact with the
um unions
Susan is absolutely right that the the
practice in in in schools or practicing
in wider multicatory trusts uh um was
improving to to meet that the sort of
challenge that you're setting out so
three particular areas where the focus
of much of of of of that Improvement
um uh work around marking much of the
workload out of out of ours is about
marking and preparation of lessons and
the Improvement uh there through school
practice and taking some of the myths
out of out of accountability and ofsted
ofsted preparation much of school's time
and the pressure on uh on on teachers
was was uh was always to do with
expectations of of what ofsted was
looking for so ofsted did
helped with the trying to drive out some
of those myths and that that certainly
helped but also a focus on on meeting
new
employment expectations flexible working
in schools has is is has been slower to
um to take uh Ruth than in many other
sectors
um and we've been working with with
multi-adamy trusts and uh and and uh
other experts across the system of how
uh especially uh because of a
um the primary system is very heavily uh
um tilted towards a female Workforce how
flexible working
um can be better integrated indeed we'd
only adjust in the last uh a few months
uh announced a additional support and
through
um uh uh for Ambassador schools to
actually promote um some of that
practice on on flexible working so
um marking and and and and preparation
uh taking out some of the myths out of
out of accountability uh and a new uh is
some of the big changes that brought
down some of those workload hours
Jeffrey well I I hear those answers but
talking to one of my heads the other day
uh there's a whole load of pressures out
there over and above these normal school
activities ahead dealing with school
activities you know exams budgets uh
recruitment of teachers and so on
they're now having to deal with a whole
range of of social problems you know
social problems in the parents social
problems in the in the pupils which you
can't just walk away from they have to
be dealt with so I mean I think the
pressure on teachers out there is
enormous and I'm not sure that I'm
hearing from either of you a real sort
of plan as to how that's going to be
dealt with otherwise we're going to
Simply I mean I I was speaking to one
head the other day you know a very good
Cotswold school it got the Sunday Times
of the Year award first time couldn't
recruit a math teacher
um so this situation is clearly getting
pretty dire in schools and I don't hear
from either of you a real plan as to how
you're going to tackle this so
is
and it's the same plan
um so
um
a lot of work
measurable impact on teachers workload I
think we all accept that the pandemic
has set us back in that as in other
areas and that we need to go back look
at the things that we did that worked
recommit and do more and that that
starts with partnership with teachers in
looking at what is driving the workload
and understanding it and that's exactly
what we did when we did the workload
plan that we set out before and that
actually has been part of our
discussions with the teacher unions
through January and February around how
we can put more things in place to work
together to take the next steps on
teacher workload and there are some
areas we will certainly look at again as
part of that including marking I think
your point on the kind of wider social
problems and the things that schools are
dealing with is really well made though
and that's where I think the the sort of
joined up portfolio that my department
has is extremely helpful because the
plans that we've set out recently on
both children's social care and last
week on special educational needs and
disability are highly relevant to some
of the things that teachers tell us
drive that additional workload that
feels as though it's a step away from
the day job of teaching children and and
so those those two plan plans and the
shorter term actions that we're taking
now to make sure that we're supporting
um the whole of the community to be
partners in in making sure that as where
children don't teachers don't feel that
they are alone and having to be social
workers uh rather than supported by a
community around them who can help those
things happen I think is extremely
important and then specifically on
Recruitment and Retention
we have
um
bursaries in place
particularly for the priority subjects
where we see the most challenging
Recruitment and those bursaries go up to
27 000 pounds with scholarships of up to
29 000 pounds for those training in
those priority subjects and we know that
um those bursaries do have an impact and
we are seeing that in the training and
recruitment figures for this year so we
take this really seriously and we've got
a plan that's both about the kind of
those core teacher workload issues but
also about the surrounding issues that
you rightly raise let me if I made Mr Mr
Clifton Brown make one addition there we
know that some of the biggest pressures
and some of the greatest of um loss from
teachers in the profession is in their
very very first years the first couple
of first couple of years for a newly
qualified newly trained teacher can be
very daunting in indeed and so that's
been a one of the the cute big focuses
of our work to improve the um through
the early careers framework a
substantial offer that was helped by
some funding from the part of the
recovery package but it has gone wider
than that to both for a dedicated uh
training support and mentoring for every
um every teacher in their first in the
first two years
93 of of all uh um uh first early career
teachers are receiving the full package
from the from supported by the uh the
government feedback of that is uh is
really really strong uh where we're
improving it still with the uh to to
respond to some of the particular
propositions for it for how it can be
proved further but I think that is a key
part of how we can support teachers
especially because we know uh from
previous years just how many we lose in
the first first couple of years
there's quite a lot in those answers I'm
sure the profession will want to digest
that and I think it's probably a subject
we want to return I was thinking about
the same in fact um we've when we've um
we ask members of the house to give us
any thoughts they have on our hearings
and we had a lot on this um I
particularly call out afsel Khan MP
Samantha Dixon MP thank him Debonair and
pin Valerie as MP Who provided us with
some actually quite heartbreaking
evidence from their schools and
recruitment was a very big theme in
those um and some other evidence which
I'll touch on later but but recruitment
real shortages of teachers and this is
going to really have an impact on
ketchup so while a slightly separate
subject actually everything comes into
catch up so we'll I think we'll touch on
some of that in the hearing but we may
well come back to it just to give you
advanced warning Zach and I heard um I
can turn to Olivia Blake and Pina Ms
Blake um thank you Jaren good morning to
the witnesses um just to add to the
evidence that we received from
um The Honorable member for Walsall
valve um
I want to just touch on the condition of
school buildings and now you may know
that there was quite a serious incident
in my constituency where a piece of
cladding fell off and hit the head of a
parent collecting their child and led to
significant injury
um this wasn't picked up as a risk in
the recent condition survey of the
school and the school's actually not
categorized in the most serious category
how confident are you that the surveys
are picking up all issues that schools
should be aware of and how accurate do
you think the risk rating is of the
schools that have been surveyed
thank you so we
there is no form of condition survey
that a surveyor will tell you can
reliably
guarantee that it has picked up every
possible issue that a building might
suffer what we try to do is make sure
that we have as much information as we
possibly can in order to make our
assessment of risk as good as it can
possibly be but one of the reasons why
we have
um raised School building issues as a
risk is that as we build a more and more
comprehensive picture we see more and
more more risk that we understand and we
obviously take immediate action where
there is uh risk in the school estate
but we also know that there will be a
level of unknown risk underneath that
and that's one of the reasons why
um and and that's driven by
um the age profile of the school estate
partly so we had a huge bulge in
building in the school estate around
um in the post-war period both around
demography and population and the
raising of the school leaving age and so
there's a big clump of buildings in the
estate that are coming to towards the
end of their design Life all at the same
time
and that's why we've invested so much so
you know we put 15 billion into
um sorry about 13 billion since 2015
into keeping schools safe and
operational
um and then we've got the school
rebuilding program which will rebuild or
refurbish buildings at 500 schools over
the next decade we've also got
um that the work you described through
the conditioned data survey which allows
us to Target both individual schools but
also actually School types that we know
may come with elevated risk so for
example we identified a particular set
of system builds where we were seeing
higher levels of risk and we then went
and targeted all of the schools that had
that building type so again that's
that's one of the ways that we mitigate
for the fact that that there is just no
survey that can completely eliminate
your risk of something unknown what we
try and do then is feed the data back in
so we can understand the risk profile
more broadly and address it
I mean this is a secondary point to the
risk to life risks that's been
identified in the surveys but buildings
such as this school that I'm talking
about a cold damp some have blind spots
which means that they require extra
staff just to make sure that all
children are within sight in the lower
years
How are schools meant to balance their
budgets with all these conditions and
issues that they're trying to tackle and
is there a bigger plan around making our
schools warmer and more and eco-friendly
I suppose as well yeah so we announced
another 500 million pounds
in 2223 which was allocated out to
schools and colleges specifically for
improving buildings with a focus on
Energy Efficiency
and that again allows schools to
specifically Target some of those issues
that go to keeping schools
uh
woman winter and cool in summer in a way
that
um helps them to reduce energy cost and
improve the sustainability and the
impact on the planet as well
and do you feel that the plan is
adequate enough to tackle all the issues
with this model of schools that you've
kind of been mentioning and so on the
specific system
on the specific system build that I
described those are all scheduled as
part of the school rebuilding program
there's the the second when will that
end when will we see that final result
so the school rebuilding program is a
decade-long program but we front load
the areas of greatest risk in the
programs
I would need to get back again
um the um uh
um there are other sort of
um construction type based issues so the
other one we're looking at which again
you may well have talked to colleagues
in health about is
um reinforced durated autoclave concrete
and we are again going back around and
asking School some really dedicated
questions about reinforced aerated
autoclave concrete because again it
isn't something that is always easy to
spot
through
survey so we're going background and
testing and checking for that
um if the question is am I confident
that the scale of the programs we have
at the moment will eliminate risk across
the school is that I can't say that but
what I can say is that we have got the
best possible information we have to
allow us to Target the money in the
programs we have at the areas of
greatest risk and make sure that we're
reducing the risk across the school
state all the time it just was finally a
nice best off that's obviously another
big issue that's coming up regularly but
also publication of these conditions
surveys do you think that it would be in
the best interests of parents to be able
to see these conditioned surveys they've
not yet been published yeah so we we
have we've we've obviously given the
condition data collection reports to
schools and their relevant local
Authority or Academy trust already so
every school's got its own and they can
use those alongside their own surveys
and safety checks because of course
technically the responsibility for the
condition of school buildings is with
the um responsible Authority which is
the the local Authority for local
Authority schools all the trust for
trust schools
um and we also published summary
findings from the data collection in
2021 so I mean
I'm sure some schools share those with
parents already we've also
um committed to publish the full data
set it's taking us a little bit of time
to do it it contains 1.2 billion data
points it's quite large
um and so getting that ready for
publication in a way that means it will
be helpful and make sense just takes a
little bit of time
asbestos asbestos yes so we expect all
local authorities governing bodies and
Academy trust to have robust asbestos
management plans in place and we
obviously follow HSE guidance on
asbestos
um and we published refreshed guidance
for schools in 2020
um having launched the asbestos
management Assurance process in 2018
um and uh again we've spoken about this
in the committee before we had it we we
had uh 93.3 of schools who took part by
November 2021 in that first round of
asbestos management processes and we are
we then
um working our way through the remaining
schools who hadn't responded to that
collection uh and
um about uh 24 of those non-responders
have now been visited through the
condition data collection to program and
the rest are scheduled through the rest
of the program to make sure that we pick
up the non-responders and and just
finally when would you imagine that the
the risks that you've highlighted would
allow for school buildings to move down
your risk register rather than being
second
I but because of the issue I described
about that kind of Bulge and building
I don't think it's going to come down
the risk register very soon I think
we're going to need to continue to put a
lot of focus and attention on this
interesting sobering in 2023 is that we
are still talking about poor school
buildings very briefly Mr Louis thank
you chair um on a more positive note I'm
very grateful to DFE for
um several successful bids we had in
Bexley for the conditional Improvement
funds I've seen already firsthand the
positive impact that's having on the
education of local students I'm hoping
and more new buildings are open next
year which I look forward to visiting a
quick question for me just as a
follow-up obviously we're in this key
window now of 20 to 25 years after PFI
what kind of support is DFE providing to
schools that may have buildings that are
coming up at the end of their life and
they're having to consider what they do
of them next please exactly yeah so
we've got a dedicated program for
schools that are transitioning out of
pfis to effectively support those
transitions the the there were there are
because of the way the PFI program
worked there are quite a lot of
different circumstances you may be in
with a PFI building and so we try and do
that on a relatively in a relatively
bespoke way with those schools as they
come off so if there's an academy or
local school that needs advice they can
get in touch with a dfus okay
but it's French
just one very brief question within this
10-year program obviously you can't do
all schools at once and obviously you've
got to prioritize and obviously you
should be prioritizing things like
Asbestos and PRC concrete but may I
suggest to you there's a third category
you need to prioritize and this arose
from the school in my constituency which
was using Porter cabins that had a
design life for 25 years and was 40
years in the local Authority only wanted
to continue to repair them they were
boiling hot in the summer and freezing
cold in the winter worse still there was
a serious leak in one of them above the
electricity meter and all the local
Authority wanted to do was to repair
them really we should be looking at
replacing these Porter cabins for some
more modern arrangements so can we add
that to the list of important priorities
please
so again we we always prioritize based
on
um
based on risk and impact and so if
there's
whatever the form of the risk is we will
we will look at that
at the prioritization
drum and MP thank you just say the
education committee is doing an inquiry
on teach Recruitment and Retention so
perhaps we could do it we are blessed on
this committee that a number of our
members are on more than Mobility
for that so um you're announced about t
levels today
um and you're delaying some of them what
can I just ask what impacts that going
to have on the young people that we're
looking forward to doing those
particular ones I think hairdressing
barbering and Beauty therapy craft
enzyme media broadcast and production
and you've also deferred the catering to
your level as well so what impacts that
can happen to those young people
thank you and um and the first thing I
want to say is I want to apologize to
you we're hoping to take those two
levels in September and actually to the
colleges who were preparing to offer
them because I know work has gone into
that uh what we've announced today is
that we are delaying because the advice
we've had from uh I fate and from
offqual is that they're not confident
enough of the quality of the
um work that have been done the
materials have been prepared and one of
the things that we have really been very
clear on with t levels is that we want
to prioritize quality and make sure that
the qualifications are really good and
are really setting young people up for
success and so it was a very difficult
decision for ministers to make and uh we
we wish we hadn't put them in the
position of having to make it but
um
that priority on making sure that when
we do start particularly when students
start on a brand new qualification they
actually take a bit of risk I talk to T
level students quite often about
um the fact that they are pathfinding
with us and helping us to develop
qualifications but I don't think we
should ask them to take unreasonable
risk on qualifications where there's a
challenge with quality and one of the
things we did is we prepared to make
this announcement was talk to Providers
about making sure they were confident
that they had alternative courses that
they could offer to young people and
they were confident about that and they
were also Keen that we made the
announcement as quickly as possible once
we'd identified the issues which is what
we've done in order to make sure there's
time to plan
are you confident that just a year you
know you're just deferring it by year
that is going to rectify all those
issues uh yes I am um the the
um
there are there are some specific issues
related to a a particular
awarding organization and we've had
really good conversations with that
awarding organization
um and with others which puts us in a
good position with the years deferral
okay and and for the young people that
aren't haven't got the qualifications
take T levels that have been taking
b-techs uh what are you going to do for
them because you're getting rid of the B
checks so we're not getting rid of vtecs
what we're doing is we are removing btex
that overlap with certain levels but
we'll retain many b-techs that don't
overlap with t levels and um and we've
also looked at so so
um a lot of young people take btex as
part of mixed programs of study with a
levels and those smaller b-tech
qualifications that that form part of
those mixed programs of study will
continue and and the work that has been
done over recent years on uh quality of
b-techs have helped to position the
position where we're really confident
about that but one of the really
enduring challenges of the vocational
education system in this country has
been
enormous complexity
so whereas we have a relatively simple
system on the general qualification side
which most people understand and can
explain we've had a spectacularly
complicated qualifications landscape for
students taking vocational
qualifications and we have typically
layered new things on top of old things
in a sort of endless geological set of
strata which makes it extremely
difficult for people to navigate the
system for employers to understand it
for parents to understand what their
children might be doing and we really
want to simplify and streamline and to
say if we've got really good
qualifications like T levels equivalent
of three a levels these are large
qualifications that we will
really slim down so we don't have things
that are effectively kind of similar but
not quite the same
in that space so there will be
qualifications like beatex for young
people that hadn't not able to take T
levels so I'm looking at catering
hairdressing maybe they they're not they
can't haven't got the academic
qualifications to to do T levels because
you have to get a GCSE in maths in
English for instance are you going to
provide qualifications for them so the
the
um T levels are a level for a really
rigorous level three qualification a
level equivalent there isn't actually an
entry requirement you don't have to have
maths in English to get onto a t-level
some colleges are currently setting that
as an entry requirement party because
the qualifications are new and partly
because they are quite challenging and
rigorous but it's not part of the kind
of design of T levels that you have that
you you're required to have English and
maths in order to enter them and I was
talking to a group of t-level students
um actually on one of our DFE virtual
visits so we do physically make
available to every body so that the
department can see things they're less
familiar with
um and the the tutor there was saying
that actually his T level he'd seen
students with a lot of different
starting points have real success on his
t-level and that his view was that in
some other colleges the the requirements
being made around entry
were effectively kind of
um
but were partly responding to the
newness of the qualification and the
development of teaching in the
qualification and the critical thing is
that we are getting young people up to
um sounded at the end of the
qualification it is really good quality
and really worthwhile and that we aren't
reducing that standard in order to
effectively give the illusion of more
access
um to more students now there will be
some students for whom in level three
course is not appropriate and level two
courses will remain for those students I
know where we need to get on so yes
thank you very much uh Mrs Drummond I
just wanted one for one final point
before going into the main session and
thank you for your patience uh and
dealing with these other topics but
um in London we're seeing a lot of
dropping of school roles um so in my
umbara but elsewhere we're seeing
numbers reduce and yet there are still
new free schools in the pipeline across
and obviously London's a bit of a hot
spot for that is there any plan to put a
break on or reduce new free schools
opening where pupil roles are dropping
in an area
we look at every free school project
even though a initial commitments may
have been given to ensure that that
there is a place need for it and and we
have continued to take free school
projects out of the system to cancel
them when the need is is not there is
there a point but a quick point of no
return where you wouldn't cancel the
free school the the only point of no
return is where is when a signed
um a funding agreement with the uh with
the trust is very helpful to hear thank
you very much indeed and I want to just
put on record our thanks to all those
who put in evidence to this session we
had a really really interesting package
of evidence some very heartbreaking as
I've highlighted uh not not just from
empties I mentioned them earlier but
from from very many other groups and
that's been particularly helpful in our
deliberations ahead of this session and
I'd like to then kick off on the the
main topic which is education recovery
in schools and I'll start with Olivia
Blake and penis Blake thank you chair
just to Susan Akron Hood if that's okay
when will we start to see the Gap in
attainment between disadvantaged pupils
and other pupils start to close again
as soon as possible
um so one of the one of the most uh
I think for everybody in the department
and actually everybody across the system
one of the most
um
dispiriting really effects of the
pandemic has been that widening of the
attainment gap which we were
successfully closing before the pandemic
so
if I use the disadvantage Gap Index
figures so this is I'll just really
briefly explain what it is because
they're a bit of a sort of string of
numbers but we use a disadvantage Gap
Index both at Q stage 2 and key stage
four which is arrived at by ranking
every people in the country and then
looking at the differences between
disadvantages and advantaged because I
think we need to cut to the officers
rather than sorry if we were perfectly
equal it would be zero if we were
perfectly unequal it would be 10.
um in 2011 that Gap at Key Stage 2 was
3.34 and it reduced steadily
3.23 in 2012 3.10 and sorry 3.10 in 2015
down to 2.90 in 2018
in 2022 it was back to 3.23 not quite as
wide as in 2011 but backwards but but
going significantly backwards and that
has been the relentless
looking at how we can close that
attainment Gap has been the Relentless
focus of our education recovery work and
it's why pretty much every element of
the education recovery program has been
tilted towards disadvantaged people so
[Music]
um
both the national tutoring program The
Recovery Premium which is paid to people
premium pupils actually everything we
know about the investment in
um
teacher Education and Training which is
another very large part of the recovery
program although that benefits every
pupil we also know that good quality
teaching benefits disadvantaged pupils
the most
um and so I I would I would hope to see
narrowing starting from this summer
Blake
um so Mr Archer then how confident are
you that they uh the department is doing
enough to tackle this the difference
Advantage Gap given as a myth and Hood
said there the Gap is bigger now than
any point since 2012. so I think the
right right through
um the pandemic and certainly from the
moment that it was clear that that
disadvantaged Gap was opening we have
focused sharply uh on that issue we've
distributed funding
um around the national tutoring program
so that it focuses very much on
disadvantaged pupils The Recovery
Premium it was different to the catch-up
premium because we distributed it
according to a disadvantage and then
according to both disadvantage and the
differential between primary and
secondary so focusing on the places
where need was greatest
um and you know in the school's white
paper as we forward and more generally
there is a package of measures which
looks at those things which are most
likely to drive really good engagement
from all pupils and particularly for
disadvantaged peoples and the fact that
we expect for example the national tree
tuning program to be an ongoing part of
the system is I think a testament to
that
desire to see that Gap close
and the way in which we have
incentivized teachers to work in the
most disadvantaged places too I think is
a really important part of that so I
think it is a strong package of measures
and I think that you know the opening of
The Gap over the pandemic is one of the
worst you know impacts of that period
And I think there is a good package of
measures now in place to help us to move
that Gap and so um you know so in a way
do you feel that it is enough
so I mean one can always do more um but
I think that the package that we have in
place is a good strong one looking
forward and indeed building on things
that have happened during the pandemic
to move us to a better place
okay and Miss Upland can I just ask when
you'd hope to eliminate the disadvantage
Gap completely
so
um it would be wonderful to eliminate
this Advantage Gap completely I asked
the
team whether there was any country
around the world that had so far
completely eliminated its disadvantage
Gap and there isn't and that means that
I'm a little bit reluctant to promise
the committee a date by which we will
manage to have done that but I do think
we should be able to reduce the Gap at
least as quickly as we did in the 10
years before the pandemic we've we know
we can do that we did it and we ought to
be setting ourselves the challenge of
going that fast or faster and continuing
to close just so but so it's as fast
that's still a decade
the year before the pandemic
you can go faster than that we will but
we appreciate a lot of the issues as
we've had from the heart-wrenching
evidence isn't just about what's
happening in schools it's about home
life mental health and all the rest of
it so are you talking to other
departments oh absolutely absolutely
and in terms of vulnerable children
within that disadvantage group
um do you think another action in the
plans that you just kind of set out are
available to that specific group
yes I mean vulnerability's got lots of
Dimensions to it I mean there are there
are several things that we did of course
one of the most important was that
schools never closed for vulnerable
pupils through the pandemic and I want
to say I actually want to just take a
moment to thank teachers and heads who
kept schools open throughout the
pandemic for the most honorable children
they did most phenomenal job and I mean
I did actually want to read into the
record given kind of some recent events
that
um you know the the the huge hard work
dedication and impressive uh
um uh resolve and professionalism of
teachers through the pandemic is
something that has been an inspiration
and and and
um uh you know we we honor that we know
that teachers haven't always felt as
well supported as they wanted to be but
um we we really have been working to try
and support them as well as we possibly
can
um the
um so so yeah so in short you were
embarrassed by the recent leaked
WhatsApp messages from the former I
couldn't possibly comment on that the
um I think you're well I think we've
made your position clear and actual
people teachers will be glad to hear
absolutely you'll reward them the do we
allowed teachers to Define who was a
vulnerable pupil for the purposes of
keeping schools open during the pandemic
and that was extremely important because
vulnerability comes in many forms
um we've also got
um specific support for groups that we
know to be vulnerable so for example for
children with special educational needs
and disability where we both
um offered that support kind of right in
the early stages of the pandemic but
also for example our Recovery Premium
amounts are significantly higher for
pupils and Specialists and alternative
provision including special units in
mainstream schools
um we also have made sure that we were
working through our children's social
care responsibilities to support
children in care the the work that the
virtual school heads have done over over
the years really came into its own both
during and after the pandemic and for
example we've again I'm sure the
committee will want to come to
attendance later in the session but yes
one of one of the
um
one of the changes in attendance
patterns over time that I don't think we
talk about enough is that it used to be
the case that children in public care
had worse attendance than other children
actually they now have better attendance
than other children because of the
support they're given through
um social work in the virtual school
heads
thank you Miss Blake Mrs slick Drummond
Tempe
um yeah it's going back to attendance
particularly send
um on the education select committee
this week we talked about that so you
may have read the transcript on it a
huge number of children who send are not
attending schools
um it's just about special educational
needs and disabilities sorry yeah
um and and children from the Spanish
backgrounds too so how are you working
to make sure that those particular
groups are uh you know coming into
school and also to closing that
attainment Gap because we you you know
you you said that we're going to get
there but they're the ones that we
really need to focus on so you're doing
in specific projects to get those
particular group of children in back
into school
on attendance specifically
um just give me one second
I'm over flagged and and
so a lot of our attendance work
starts with the principle that you you
begin with support
and that's particularly important for
children who have other disadvantages
but we've set out a much stronger set of
expectations
on all of the partners in attendance so
schools trust but also think about
attendance for special education yes
we're just going to say that local
Authority is a really key partner in
that and they're a particularly key
partner for children with special
educational needs
I think there's
um there are distinction between maybe
between children and not in school
because they don't have an allocated
School place which again we're
addressing through the provision of more
places which we announced last week
alongside the publication of the special
education on leads and disability and
alternative provision Improvement plan
and
Then There are a group of children who
have a school place but but have
challenges
um in attending so again we see some
children who for example became more
anxious about attendance during the
pandemic and need habits rebuilt and
there are a set of proposals that are
around
um local authorities identifying
children most at risk and
um and creating bespoke action plans for
them where again their role for children
with special educational needs will be
particularly pronounced because of their
responsibilities in that regard and have
you got the resources to be able to put
that in place because they know local
authorities are quite stretched at the
moment
yeah so there's
um there are
for special education needs and
disability in particular
there is a kind of bringing together of
attendance resource and the special
education needs resource that local
authorities are responsible for there
are also some additional things we're
doing more widely across the attendance
piece that are relevant so that we've
got 10 expert attendance advisors
working with local authorities and
trusts in a Hands-On way to review their
practices develop plans and help them
meet the kind of new expectations that
we've set including for regular meetings
on individual persistently absent
children at local Authority level
um and we've also got work going on in
Middlesbrough piloting a mentor program
providing direct support to persistently
and severely absent children for example
so using that good practice that's
happening in some places you're you know
spreading at the rest of the country
okay
thank you so much very much Mrs Drummond
um so I just wanted to move on to the
tutoring scheme the Randstad scheme
first of all so I think Mr Archer that
was your baby so to speak and it was
interesting in response to miss Blake
that you said that you think you're
doing a good does a good job going on
but we've already highlighted in the
early bit of this session there are big
challenges and just having the right
people you know teachers in place
classroom assistance in place a lot of
evidence came up with that so but this
particular scheme the the Randstad
scheme the contract that you had with
Randstad was that 65 of pupils supported
through tradition to the partner scheme
would be disadvantaged and it's
interesting that schools had already
automatically kind of in all of the
other tutoring had programs and
disadvantaged peoples but you didn't
meet that Target so why was that and why
did you set 65 just just be interested
in your thinking behind why that was set
so it's worth um it's worth just
starting with a little bit of the
history we had some uh sorry if I could
we had a smaller scale scheme which we
had established in the early part of the
pandemic and uh when we appointed
Randstad as our delivery partner we were
looking to scale that up
um by um you know a factor of of three
or four I think
um and as part of that we established a
Target which is that we wanted to see
grandstat
um deliver
um 65 of those places to disadvantaged
pupils as you say
um that Target wasn't achieved it was
always
it was always set as a stretching Target
intended to go beyond the numbers that
we had got in the first year and I think
the target did contribute
um significantly to seeing around uh 50
of the tutoring that was undertaken
undertaken by
disadvantaged pupils so while um we
didn't hit the target that we intended
we did I think have an impact on the way
in which levels of disadvantage were
tackled by the program it's worth saying
that in the school population as a whole
27 of pupils are eligible for free
School meals of those of the population
of those tutors that number was nearer
to 50 so there was definitely a positive
skew
um to those
from disadvantaged backgrounds within
schools and we were Keen
and there's a balance in all of this
isn't there between what you dictate
from the center and what you leave to
schools who know their pupils best
um and and the permanent secretary has
already
um set
um you know how much we have valued the
work of uh teachers over the pandemic
period and leaving ultimately in their
hands which of those pupils were most
likely to benefit from tutoring was a
really important part of what we wanted
to to do so
um nobody didn't hit the target
um that's that's plain but I think the
target did contribute to
um the overall impact of uh of the
scheme okay we're going to come into a
little bit later on at tutoring more
widely but on this particular Target
money was provided to Randstad to do
this they will set this target but
didn't achieve it some exactly they only
um that they're only only half of the
tutoring was going to disadvantage
pupils I mean are you happy because
we've just talked about that huge the
Gap has increased it's going to be maybe
10 years I mean not not fixing you the
10 years and obviously we'd all hope
it'd be quicker but it could be 10 years
from what you said before that Gap is
closed again so you know given that
there's a contract that you went into
are you unhappy with that 50 percent
rate and why and why and what can you do
to try and get this targeted what could
you have done to make this we'll get
this up what did you not do perhaps yes
I mean I think the the I'd go back to
the point that
um Mr Archer made which is that we
within all of this
Randstad were working with schools but
it was ultimately schools who were
deciding which pupils were tutored and I
think I would have been very unhappy if
for example we hadn't so it's a it was
still a case that a disadvantage people
was about twice as likely to be tutored
as a non-disadvantaged people under the
scheme
and I would have been very unhappy if we
hadn't seen a significant skew towards
disadvantaged peoples but we also see in
the catch-up data that although there is
a gap there are also lots of other
pupils who've fallen behind
significantly so people with low prior
attainment whatever their disadvantaged
backgrounds have been disproportionately
affected now actually that's a pattern
we see in the school system more widely
that if you have low priority and
there's a point where it becomes
difficult to access the curriculum there
are some disadvantaged people whose
attainment is good who may have been
better served by really good quality
whole class what are you saying release
that's the definition of this
disadvantage is obviously quite narrowly
technically defined but you're saying
there are other pupils who had
disadvantages yes
um who who couldn't really just be left
because you were skewing it towards but
I mean the point is there's still pupils
who haven't had the tutoring really
isn't and that's that's the who needed
it so there's a gap
so what we did was make available as
much tutoring as we possibly could for
schools to point at the pupils they
believe needed it most and we wanted to
assure ourselves that that within that
disadvantaged peoples were were being
kind of well served and I think just as
much of people's being twice as likely
to be tutors as non-disadvantaged
peoples you know give some comfort on
that what we didn't seek to do was
prevent schools from tutoring pupils
that didn't meet a technical definition
of disadvantage and and indeed we when
we ask schools about how they targeted
the vast majority said that they use
disadvantage to Target low prior
attainment they also for example
targeted pupils in exam years and
particularly in secondary schools and
um
there's there's logic in that because
you had a group of people whose time in
school was running out effectively and
where if you didn't make the impact on
them as they approached those kind of
final public exams that the school was
running out of the opportunity to make a
difference but for a school for example
that is targeted pupils and exam years
that that would be likely to give you
slightly more non-disadvantaged pupils
but we we thought it was important that
schools had the opportunity to make
those choices that the last thing I'll
say is as we looked forward in the
program so with Randstad we were running
a kind of national offering in randstadt
we're also working with the schools to
bring them on board into the program and
so it was really important to have that
kind of a Target that we set them to
help them direct their efforts because
we also didn't want them to be
targeting schools that leaded needed it
so there was the between school and the
in-school point if that makes sense once
we moved to school-led tutoring actually
what we did was allocate the money on
the basis of pupil premium so we we did
the targeting towards disadvantage in a
different way it's interesting I mean
schools were or I mean opposite found in
there that schools were picking were
using disadvantages of the main Baseline
criteria
um so Mr McCully I mean you know we when
you look I think it may be you maybe
maybe Mr Archer
um I'm sure we could share yeah yeah uh
with your fast years of experience I'm
sure I'm sure it's not a problem with
variety of it
um but there were obviously there would
be if individual schools were making
these these individual judgments and and
we've had a lot of evidence which I
haven't got time to go into about how
well things different things work we'll
come back to some of that I think later
on
um but are you trying to get lessons
learned from the best performing schools
passed around other schools because it's
it's a it was a whole new extra thing
for schools to take on to embrace
tutoring
um and we we're not really here to
discuss well we can discuss a bit with
the national weathers of the local work
better we know there was a problem with
some of the original contracts but what
what are you doing to make sure that the
best the worst or the schools that are
still struggling with this are learning
from the better performing schools
um another really good examples that you
can point to I mean the national
teaching program has been a um uh a one
that has developed the year one year and
and the experience and the learning has
has developed um uh uh year one year so
sharing best practice is absolutely
fundamental to the to the um how are you
doing that so in in a number of ways
directly uh with um with the support
that we offer to schools we have uh
webinars we have
um uh and uh
um uh shared promotions
and we have a research that is shared we
found a fundamental
um uh program of research that has
embedded further guidance into into the
schools about what effective tutoring uh
looks like and particularly um highlight
the work of the education endowment
foundation and nfer who've been behind
uh that that research to enable a good
practice to be shared across schools and
part of our the the the the the model
that is now underpinning the the program
of the uh of the national tutoring
program uh it involves a greater role of
the of the department itself and and our
both our evidence and our
um and our direct Digital support to a
school so we have Direct Customer
Support into into schools as part of the
national uh tutoring program in a way
that we didn't have before
um and that is a key part of the sharing
directly into schools are there any um
geographical areas of the country or
types of school or that have that you
are as a category I'm asking you to name
individuals that you're very worried
about and are there any others that
would be doing a particularly good job I
have to say one of the um in the early
days we had a lot of
um worries and feedback from from uh
from different organizations that would
be differential uh rates of of
um of of of tutoring and indeed
different access to to uh tutors one of
the I think real successes of the of the
national two program is that we're not
seeing that at the moment indeed
um uh was there some of it geographical
because there was some discussion early
on yeah there was an issue but there
isn't now yes
um today in fact the sudden trust is
publishing a report uh uh that southern
trust has been uh concerned over the
years about uh that disadvantaged
children in certain areas of the country
have have not had access to tutoring
irrespective of the of the of the
central government programs and it's
been a key part of their of their
concern about social meditative for
instance of the lack of access their
report today says that the there's been
a complete turnaround in terms of access
and so uh the it's the very areas of the
of the of uh that of disadvantage that
are now increasingly benefiting from uh
the the import of of school tutoring
counteracting that that uh lack of
access where these tutors suddenly
appeared from because there was a really
deserts if I can say a little bit about
that we in the early part of the program
um we monitored really closely both take
up uh in regions and the availability of
tutors uh in regions
um and essentially there were there were
two things that I think we did to shift
the dial
um we
um encouraged
very significantly tutoring
organizations to expand their operations
so that they moved into areas where
there was less obvious availability
essentially moving them northwards from
areas where they had operated more
frequently the second thing
um that we did was respond to
um feedback from schools
um
I was going to say particularly from
from the north of England and that's
sort of true but it was it was Universal
but but skewed towards the north that
they wanted to control tutoring
themselves so the creation of the
school-led root and the increased
emphasis on the school-led route
um was precisely about
um responding to feedback from schools
including those
um from the north where the the
um the tutoring Market if you like was a
little little less well developed at the
beginning of the process thank you we'll
come back to some of the issues on
tutoring a little later but I'm going to
turn to Jeffrey Clifton Brown yes could
I turn to the subject that strumming was
talking about and this is absences
in and I think probably perhaps first
come to you Mr McCully if I may please
we know that in the Autumn and spring
terms of 21 22 the average absence rate
fell for all pupils by 7.4 percent but
compared to 4.5 in the same terms before
the pandemic in 2018-19 but particularly
for disadvantaged people the rate was
10.4 in 2122 compared with 7.2 1819 so
whilst that absences is damaging all
pupils it's particularly damaging
disadvantaged people
um can you just fill out for us a bit
more what the Department's plans are to
deal with absences yeah and I I
recognize those figures and those
figures are are improving which is a an
important
um uh point to recognize uh figures are
the the most recent improvements
um uh um are coming out to the back of
of uh of reductions in illness over the
uh over the um uh the end of last year
so I mean illness illness and the
prevalence of um of uh you know
respiratory uh infections and things
like that is a is a is part and parcel
of managing uh of understanding and
managing attendance so it's improving
but as you as you rightly uh point out
it's uh there's more more to be done uh
key things about uh the Improvement of
of uh Team resistance children need to
be in school that's the that's the most
important place for them so the the key
actions I think and indeed Susan refer
to that in a little earlier of of this
uh inquiry and the strong expectations
that that attendance is everyone's
responsibility at in school leaders and
those around school and parents and so
the the uh the guidance that
um we still fully intend to make uh
statutory uh when we have the uh the
solicitive opportunity to do so
um but um but is already guiding
um Partners schools local authorities
and uh uh and and others that that is
that brings all those actions together
and data is really important and we now
through
um a revisions and I I think quite a
revolutionary change to the way in which
um schools
um of offer the department at their
attendance data so that we can have a
full picture and that schools can share
that and uh means that schools and the
department and other partners can can
extract from the uh that that data
Trends and particular issues and
particular solutions to that within a
way that we've never had before and I
think that's a real important step
forward to um to the sort of uh some
real management through information and
through data and Leadership I think is
really important we have
um a what we call the attendance action
Alliance both at National level but it's
increasingly being replicated at local
levels as well which brings together
um those key players who can make a
difference both in terms of the
leadership that they they they bring to
their sectors and the expectations of
the contribution of different sectors
and to give one example how that
generally turns to action at the local
level for instance one of the
um uh uh one of the key participants at
the national level is is is Paul Tom uh
chief executive of of a of a one of the
our very best multi-canal trust Delta he
has established a whole series of of
demonstration Partnerships across other
multi-academy trusts about how to act
um the best on on attendance uh I'd only
add
um uh the sort of targeted support that
that Susan mentioned a little uh earlier
in terms of the working with um sort of
local authorities especially through the
supporting families and virtual schools
program at work was that because that
gets to the most vulnerable children so
you can see from that
um
it's a full set of of
um of sort of complementary activities
because attendances every needs to be
everyone's business that's a very
helpful answer
I think everybody's now agreed from
those figures that absence is
particularly affect disadvantaged
children and and going back to the
chairs question to miss Akron Hood
earlier on attainment gap which I found
the answer is slightly alarming that it
was going to take another 10 years to
get back to where we were in 2012. if
I've interpreted your answer correct
Miss Sacramento considering we now know
a lot more about What mechanisms work
and what don't work to close this
attainment Gap I would have thought we
were to be able to do a lot better than
that uh in 12 years but clearly one of
the things of closing that attainment
Gap is this a business of absence from
schools particularly for disadvantage
pupils so what more work and why is it
that disadvantaged children have a
higher absence from
and what can we do about it and I think
what we what uh everyone tells us what
Partners tell us and I I mentioned the
the uh the attendance action Alliance it
is both a
um it's not just a a point of leadership
it's also uh enables the the better
understanding of what uh works right the
way through the system so what we have
been uh learning through that is the
whole range of different effective
approaches that that
um great schools great trusts working
with the local authorities have been
bringing to bear and it the the whole
range of different individual approaches
whether it's work with individual
parents whether it's uh the direct
support
um often typically phoning you know they
practice phoning parents up in the in
the in the morning direct mentoring
activities
the support first approach is is a is a
is a a phrase that you'll hear a lot
from from all of the uh members of the
action Alliance and their their
counterparts at the at the local levels
because it it is a reminder of how the
the combinations of different support
needs to be brought together to address
the particular
um needs challenges of different
individual um uh disadvantaged young
people so I'm I'm very interested in
your data-driven approach to this
um uh I I see you will be able to see
differences between schools and Trends
taking place within schools now one of
the anecdotal trends that we're hearing
is that actually abscesses are higher on
a Friday
um uh so you should be able to pick that
up and then and then start to do
something about it
um so
the
the the data really does make a
difference and what we're able to do now
is
um draw attendance data directly out of
school management information systems on
a daily basis and we now do that for
about 80 of the State financial schools
in the country uh we've put that in
place over just a little bit more than a
year
um and that's schools voluntarily
signing up to give us that information
the burden is zero for schools because
it just pulls straight out of the it's
system but what it allows us to do is
look in a much more fine-grained way at
patterns across time to see things in
much more real time and then what we
offer back to schools in the system is
views of their data and we've just
introduced the latest
um shift to more benchmarking data which
allows them to compare themselves and
again we'll keep refining and developing
that so they can look at themselves
against other similar skills and again
we know that on other topics that
benchmarking approach really does help
on the days of the week this is
something we actually picked up using
our rather clunkier and less elegant
data collection mechanisms during covid
and it's one of those things that I
think anecdotally people have always
known to be true but we've never been
able to see it in the data before
because previously our attendance data
collection was always a sort of annual
School census mechanism
but what's the what's the information
you're getting so it's true that the
data shows that attendance is lower on a
Friday than other days of the week it it
it's it's a you know and a little bit
lower on Monday that is really a matter
for parents isn't it from the school to
get on to parents and say look it's not
acceptable just because the parents are
working at home that the the pupils and
children can stay away from school on a
Friday I don't think you can infer that
it's all about working from home because
again anecdotally it's a pattern that
pre-existed the pandemic and from some
children for example it may be that you
know again we still see the biggest
driver of absence of being illness so
for example if you're ill it may be that
after four days of school you've you're
exhausted so it it I think should be
very careful that what the data tells us
is that absence is lower on a Friday but
you don't know what the cause is okay
but just finally on this Amazon's
business
um I like the idea that your policy of
feeding back to schools the deity or see
how quickly does that happen so they can
see it in real time on the same day real
time yes that's very good thank you very
much
um it's it's completely
move on to a completely different
subject and there's the send review and
firstly
um uh
we this committee
um uh in its treasury minute response
agreed with the with the recommendation
set a Target implementation for the send
report of autumn 2020. now mostly we
have now had it uh from the
Parliamentary under secretary on the 2nd
of March 23.
three years later why did it take so
long
so first of all I actually wanted to
sorry I'm going to need a glass one I
just wanted to thank this committee this
committee has been absolutely dogged and
uh dedicated to making sure that we
um uh not only kind of um uh do this
well and seriously but that we we we
keep ourselves
um moving on it and that's I appreciate
that that's right we'd love to take the
things but but if you could answer the
question about the white took so long so
when we've spoken about this in this
committee before so the the
it was absolutely right to start with a
green paper and to make sure that we
gave time for consultation because the
one thing we know about send the reform
is that it will not succeed unless it is
done in partnership with parents and
others in the system so the first thing
is we knew that in order for this to be
a successful process we would need to
have a significant period of
consultation that there was a delay in
getting that consultation document out
and that was partly because we had to
divert so in the very early part of the
pandemic we diverted people to do
pandemic response
after that we did work on a on the green
paper and we started to share it with
partners
and again we spoke about this at the
time in the committee we had concerns
from partners that it didn't
sufficiently recognize the change of
circumstances due to the pandemic that
it needed more thought and more work and
again it was quite important that we
listened to that so I I know it took
longer than we had hoped but I think it
took us to a better product as a result
and I would much rather do this well
than as fast as possible and not well I
appreciate that it would be even better
to do it both fast and well
um and uh I'm I think since the
publication of that green paper we have
proceeded with quite quite good Pace
actually so with consultation all over
the summer and then in the context of
quite a lot of ministerial change uh to
publish in the this spring I think is um
not bad
and sorry I just I actually would really
like to thank colleagues in the
department who've worked on this and all
of the partners across the system who
have worked with us I'm sure that's
appreciated and and I entirely agree
with what you need you need to do it
well when it's done and it's now got a
nine point plan and it looks pretty
comprehensive so and it needs to be
because the current situation is pretty
duh
um uh so why are you not expecting to
have a full set of the new national
standards even by the end of 2025.
so
we've committed to start with the
national standards that um
touch on the things that we know people
most whatso on autism on mental health
for example
we want to go as quickly as we possibly
can in creating the national standards
but again we know that that only work if
we co-create them with others across the
system we need to make sure we're
bringing the right people together to
set the national standards and that they
are national standards that will hold
and sustain and so we we
we've set ourselves the aim of getting
as many of those kind of
um
kind of most urgent and wide spectrum
standards out as soon as possible but
um because of the range of need and
um experience that is covered by special
educational needs and disability is a
headline description we think the full
Suite of national standards is likely to
be very extensive so this is one of
those things where we hope to have a set
of national standards out that will
cover
a lot of the need that's out there but
there'll be a very long tale of
individual need where it will take us a
bit longer to get through all of the
national stuff
my problem with this is that if I were a
parent of a a child in gloucestershire
and Gloucester is particularly bad and
it's incredibly difficult to get an ehcp
plan I mean you've got to jump through
God knows how many Hoops to get one
um I'd say well that's all very well but
you know my child needs to need to need
a special needs plan now so what what
hope can you offer those parents
so I think the first thing is that I
mean as we discussed in this committee
before we're not waiting for the full
implementation of the plan in order to
take action we've got the work that
we've done through delivering Professor
value in the safety valve program which
has put hundreds of millions of pounds
into the system to help local
authorities look at and shift their
service and the center of the plan
is about making sure that
the provision that parents and children
expect is clear and that it can be
accessed by many more people without
needing to go through the process of
getting a plan so we do want to make
sure that the CP plan process is
streaming but actually what we really
want is for many many more parents to
get the support they need for their
child without having to go through a
hoop jumping process of writing a plan
of that kind and so the critical first
stage we'll look at some of the national
standards that make sure that parents
teachers and pupils know which what
should ordinarily be available including
in mainstream settings
and we've also got significant
investment in teacher training we'll
train uh several thousand more early
years special educational needs
coordinators to help identify children
who need support as soon as possible
because we know that early
identification helps avoid escalation of
need and make sure people get the
support they need earlier we were also
training 400 more educational
psychologists which will reduce the wait
times for specialist support
and we're also we've also reformed the
accountability system we'll put in place
dashboards that help people see what
those times are again take that data
focused approach where we can drive
change and of course we've also got the
announcement of 33 new special schools
and that's in addition to the 49 that
already in the free schools pipeline
because the other uh constraint in the
system is supply of those specialist
places particularly in the maintained
sector for children who need them see
the problem is if I were a head teacher
or Deputy head listening to this
exchange I'd say this is all very well
I'd love to be able to provide more
special needs out of a a statutory
Education Health Plan but I simply
haven't got the funding to do so I
haven't got staff to do it so the
evidence we've had has been very
particular particularly on classroom
assistance and one-to-one support yes
this wonderful support is you know it's
often included in the plans but it's not
really available in most of my schools
to anyone else because they simply
haven't got the stuff they're struggling
with glass sizes and assistant teachers
as they are so will the um 2.6 billion
between 2025 fund new special and
alternative provision places and improve
the existing provision come us cover
that's those situations
so the 2.6 billion is particularly
Capital provision for new specialist
School places that but but we've also
significantly increased the amount of
funding going into the system uh so we
that the high needs budget will rise to
over 10 billion pounds by next year
which is an increase of more than 50
since 2019. I mean the the
again we discussed this in the committee
before but the the challenge we're
meeting through this implementation plan
is that we have a system in which we are
both seeing costs and spending escalate
and we're not seeing people feel as
though their needs are being met and
that is partly because more and more of
the budget is being hoovered to the
highest
and because we are because we're less
able to put that support in earlier
precisely my question you know are those
not quite that very sharp end but still
need extra help I mean I was a very late
reader I needed extra help so I I know
what these but I would never have got a
health plan you know statutory ehcp plan
so it's it's people like me you know
being you know just using me as an
example that need that extra help can
you reassure them that their parents
that they're going to get there and that
and that comes back to those standards
about what should ordinarily be
available that's not just an expectation
without support that's also about trying
to because again we see very very
different patterns across the country
and we do see local authorities where
they're much more successful in wrapping
that support around lower level needs in
school one-to-one support isn't always
the right answer so for example foreign
systematic synthetic phonics I was
talking to a researcher at Cambridge the
other day who was saying to me there
used to be a thing called a garden
variety poor reader and we've
essentially eliminated the garden
variety Paul Reader by investment in in
phonics so you you now there's a really
interesting thing that Garden variety
probably locates the problem in the
child actually the problem wasn't
located in the child it was about making
sure we were giving teachers the
equipment to teach really well to a
class of children and so there's also a
slice of this that is about investment
in really good quality whole class
teaching that helps every child do their
best we could have a long discussion
about um inclusion and uh and wider
support but I think we need to move on
to mental health yes
I must take the chairs the chairs hint
and move on Mental Health
we've had lots of evidence on mental
health problems from all sorts of
witnesses
um
I think I perhaps like to start with the
mental health evidence submitted by
young minds and they say the department
for Education should meaningfully
Implement a whole school approach to
mental health well-being and social and
emotional learning across all statutory
and non-statitary guidance what what
what what more can you tell us perhaps
we start with you're nodding your head
Mr McCulley I'm sure you've dealt with
this all your life
um it would be great for your experience
I've I've just
um I agree with the with the young minds
and sort of recommendation and that is
certainly the the
um approach that we try and
promote and instill within schools and
that's why a key part of the of the
investment in in Improvement had been
around the both the identification of
and the training of senior mental leads
for every school we now have over 10 000
schools and colleges who've been helped
by by that Grant and another
um uh 10 million is is going into each
two-thirds State schools and colleges by
the end of uh this financial year so and
that with that objective of of promoting
this a whole school approach because
that's so so important because of the
range of different uh needs one of the
uh objectives in in in truly effective
mental health support is is not
necessarily to to
um uh pathologize and and and and and
make and see it as a as always a
clinical question but to have that
support in uh uh early and that's the
the the the training is is very much
with with that uh in mind and the
further roll out of of the mental health
and support teams which has been such a
big part of our joint work with uh with
NHS England
um and the Department of Health and
Social care is also fundamental to that
we have a um uh ambition to uh with the
amount of funding that has been made
available in this substantial program to
uh to reach um you know 35 percent of of
children through uh 35 of schools
through those um through that Sport and
were on track to uh to do that and the
indeed the acceleration of work through
industrial investment of the spending
review on on uh for mental health in the
Department of Health and Social care
really has has supported that
so also young minds say that the mental
health support team must sit alongside
other forms of support to ensure there's
many young people are able to access
help the work for them within the school
environment and of course part of that
is actually recognizing that a
particular pupil has a mental health
problem so there's two elements to this
let's see the the old ordinary teacher
who hopefully has had some training to
actually recognize this problem with the
particular people and then there's the
mental health support teams actually
providing that help so could you just
address those two particular bits again
so important I once again agree
wholeheartedly with young young minds uh
there and they did hold the whole
concept of a joint program between
um the DFE and dhsc is to ensure that
the join between health and education is
is replicated right the way through the
uh through the system so for instance I
have
um a a team of of Regional workers who's
who's whose Prime Focus is to make sure
that that when the department of when
NHS England is establishing those those
teams they effectively joined to the uh
uh the leadership and actions of head
teachers in in those areas to provide
the um the sort of whole school approach
that young man's is talking about
and then they say that the rollout of
mental health support teams and
designated senior leads for mental
health should be accelerated to all
schools by 2028. similarly reflected
actually another evidence from the
church
so you've said 35 I think our schools
will get it so yeah if it's working if
we hope it will why not everyone and the
that level of investment um which was um
uh secured in the in the last spending
review takes us to that level and going
beyond that requires
um we would provide more investment and
that will need to be subject to the to
uh the the next spending review but
there'll be uh the the success of the of
the work so far will be a strong
um point of evidence and uh and and
indeed sort of encouragement uh for
future decisions cohorts of children
won't get support in the time they're in
school yeah going as fast as we can with
the with the resources that are that
have been made available these there
will be young adults who will have
suffered but not had the support at a
adolescent stage
and you can with the resources I can't
believe this section Mr McCully without
talking about mental health of teachers
I can't just uh tear it up and find it
at the moment the evidence but we've had
evidence about mental health as we
support the teachers what more can be
done well I mean it's all part of the
general pressure that I was referring to
earlier on teachers but at the worst end
it does result in mental health problems
for teachers and therefore absenteeism
um what more can be done to support them
and I hear that a lot of all my
conversations with school leaders and
and uh and and and and teacher unions
that is a we've seen that more of that
from from from from covid as I'm sure
you uh recognize and we and we put in
place a um and funded a
um a support program uh particularly on
uh for for leaders of schools because
that was where the biggest pressures on
on covid uh um and that's been uh uh so
welcome so much that we expand that we
expanded the uh the the program
it's something that we we initiated a
well-being Charter which all which was
signed by
um by organizations across the sector
focusing on on on the principles of of
support for about for teachers and for
um uh uh and for for school for school
leaders and that once again brings
together the focus um that needs to be
made because you know it's only with
with with confident and well-supported
uh teachers at the sort of uh attainment
uh objectives that we've been talking
about earlier and the questions can be
achieved so it's a it's a fundamental
priority of of uh both the right thing
to do important for teachers but also
for their wider objectives definitely
it's almost required of an employers to
provide that support we have to say when
we have evidence of words this is from
The Honorable Walsall who got evidence
from different schools one one head
saying I see some of my staff ready to
crumble and that's not right some of
this is impacting covid for some of the
erosion of funding for years and the
funding of course Services supporting
schools and families having a charter on
well-being is all very well Mr McCully
but the pressures on schools before
kobit were immense that they've
exacerbated hugely
um so I mean I think the points in the
evidence are well made I won't go into
that anymore now at this point so
Jeffrey if you've got any glasses no I
think that's very quickly
um
on a mental health just just ask um
to how will you ensure a whole school
approach is inclusive for example to
students who may have uh hearing loss
and deafness or a specific learning
disability or a neurodivergence how will
you ensure that the offer is there for
all those students
um
one of the reasons and and Susan has
brought a copy with her because it's
something that we all we will
um really really see as one of the
fundamental priorities one send
Improvement plan that we've just been
talking about in answer to to Mr
Dickerson Brown's question has mental
health as a a as a fundamental as one of
the uh the priorities there because it
recognizes how mental health
um uh needs to be mental health support
needs to be both integrated around a
number of other of of specifics of uh
challenges and include men include
mental health physical mental conditions
as well so
um mental health is so you have a
British document that's written through
that document and just finally uh do you
think there's been any impact on I've
learned long-term health conditions on
attendance for example we know there's
been a spike in Eating Disorders along
covid and have you done any assessment
on that when looking at the attendance
I think we're learning um so the answer
is not not yet I mean I can't raise you
because of time
I mean it's certainly true that when you
look at the persistent absence figures
the biggest growth and persistence
absence is illness related rather than
unauthorized absence related
the the persistence
School sessions are missed and what
we've got at the moment for this year is
for the Autumn term only now there's
quite a lot of illness going on and
because it's a percentage of the term
you only have to have missed seven days
to last term to have been classified as
persistently absent and quite a lot of
people who got flu would have been off
for seven days also things are
circulated so because we were locked up
for two years exactly and so
disentangling that from things actually
are some data manage takes us a little
bit of time okay thank you Miss Blake
and we're going to move on just before
we move on though you mentioned the work
to wellbeing Charter in the evidence
from the children of young people's
mental health coach and they are they
talked about the well-being for
Education recovery program
it's that that's what's happened to that
is that the same thing as the as the
charter part of that the charter was
specifically for um for um for teachers
and and leaders you know the well-being
for education program was a a set of
Investments around
um particularly programs and it was so
it's finished now
from uh the first phase was in May 2021
where we invested seven million uh
pounds and then uh building on the
success of of uh eight million pounds
that had gone before so it was a
specific
um level of investment for the last two
years and have you evaluated that
and that all of our programs are
evaluated at the office but I haven't
got the evaluation if you would write to
us with the evaluation of that because I
mean relatively in small although it's a
lot of money it's relatively
be very angry if I say that's not very
much money but overall across the
country if that has achieved results so
be interested to know why what it
achieved and why it's not continuing I
can tell you it
served about 14 000 schools and colleges
and it was principally about expert
training and Sport and resources for
staff I think we just need to see the
data about what it achieved before the
money because it's an interesting
element to a much bigger problem now
we're going to move on to Jonathan ugly
MP thank you chair and if we can go into
managing the recovery program and I'm
going to start off with paragraph 1 16
of the Nao report where it says schools
have not used all the recovery funding
that DFE has made available we estimate
that by the end of the 2021-22 financial
year there was a 226 million 14
underspend against the available funding
so perhaps to Mrs Ackland Hood why did
schools not take up all of the funding
so um we we recognize that figure and
that represents under spend on summer
schools and on the tuition partner and
academic Mentor pillars of the program
what it doesn't reflect and this isn't
because the na didn't do right is
because we hadn't
um
we hadn't got far enough through to
solidify the figures is that we actually
took some of that underspend on the
tuition partners and academic Mentor
pillars and we fed it back into the
school-led tutor tutoring program
because this relates to the year in
which we saw lower numbers than expected
on tuition partners and academic mentors
and then much higher numbers than
expected on school then tutoring which
is why despite the underspend we
delivered the amount of tutoring we said
we were going to deliver so we hit the
target
okay and how does that move on into the
2223 Financial year or the even out as a
result so no we will still see some
someone so again if I just take you
through the so the part of understanding
that relates to the summer schools
program
was partly about so we
we made that money available as part of
the recovery announcement actually
relatively close to the summer term in
the end and so we wanted to make sure
money wasn't the limiting factor so we
made a lot of money available and we
assumed that schools might want to do
two-week summer school programs and to
and we made enough money available
effectively to cover the whole of the
transition cohort going into year seven
and what happened in practice was that
although a very large number of schools
took it up not every school around the
summer school and many of them ran one
week rather than two weeks summer
schools and that's what drove the under
spend and there was also a bit of
management to the figures and then on um
ntp
um again when we moved to so so for the
year in question we saw that lower than
expected Demand on tuition partners and
academic mentors and higher than
expected Demand on uh school-led
tutoring and also School the teaching
was cheaper than tuition Partners
academic mentors what you see for this
year
which was reflected in our supplementary
estimates is that
um we're still seeing some schools
delivering a bit cheaper than our
funding rates but we've also
um seen uh some schools delivering
um less tutoring them we made the money
available for and we've we are we've got
a program to talk to schools that aren't
delivering tutoring what we did was we
through the school-led tutoring
mechanism was that we allocated money
out to all schools based on pupil
premium on the assumption that they
would do that all of them would do
tutoring for all of their people premium
pupils and so the mechanism was designed
to make sure the money was announced in
schools and wasn't a barrier
but when you do it that way around you
do tend to find that not not everyone
will do it and not everyone will do it
to the extent that you expect it so some
money then comes I wondered if I might
just add one thing which is which is the
tower Target for tutoring overall was
hit in in that in that Year we We
reached and exceeded our and our only
two million talks so it wasn't the week
wasn't that we missed missed that
um metric okay so look at looking at
school they're tutoring uh in paragraph
221 Eno report says it says DFE relies
on schools to report how they have spent
their funding allocation for school
they're tutoring if a school has
provided fewer hours of tutoring than
expected or provided the expected number
of hours but spent less than a funded
allocation the esfa seeks to recover the
overpayment by deducting it from future
payments so I think to miss Archer how
much unspent money for school they're
tutoring to expect to recover from
schools you know I mean we're we are
still going through that process
um so I um can't give you a figure for
that I think the uh supplementary
estimates figure for this year
um suggests
um
um that you know we we are expecting not
to use 165 million uh of that funding um
that's the best estimate I have I have
at present we are finalizing that
process of recovering from schools and
final figures obviously will will come
later and appear in our when when do the
final figures come out in uh in our um
accounts departmental accounts when will
that be when
so uh in paragraph two spot eight it
says of the Nao report it says DFE
intended that the Recovery Premium would
help schools make up for lost teaching
for disadvantaged people specifically
and I know that you've been talking
about disadvantaged pupils uh and I
think you said there's been an increased
take up
um but the na over report uh points out
that GFE have not routinely collected
information on how schools have used the
Recovery Premium so perhaps Mr Archer
what what Assurance do you have that
schools are using the Recovery Premium
to support disadvantaged pupils
specifically
so I think there are two or three things
I would I would say in this space the
first goes back to
um the question of
the extent to which we rely and rightly
rely on schools and teachers to decide
how best to use funding for their pupils
my second point would would be that your
interventions and the interventions
which work best for disadvantaged people
some of them and tutoring is clearly an
example of this
um are sharply focused on those
individual disadvantaged pupils some of
them are about the nature of whole class
teaching and the nature of teaching more
generally we have
uh sharpened the way in which we expect
schools to deliver the Recovery Premium
in the same way that we have the pupil
premium through
um
providing a list of eef approved or eef
identified interventions which make a
big difference and we expect each year a
school to provide a statement about how
they have used their pupil premium in in
the broad not for every individual
people but in the broad and that
includes the way in which they have used
their Recovery Premium
um and I think the funding itself is
final point is is a really big signal we
have provided schools with Recovery
Premium funding on the basis of the
number of their pupils who are eligible
for free School meals and signaled very
clearly that meeting that disadvantage
Gap is the is the purpose of that
funding and I think you're doing a
review of these uh Recovery Premium
strategy statements are you not we are
indeed and when's that likely to
delivered
the process is ongoing at the moment I
don't have the date for that in in front
of me but I know I can certainly let you
know yes and other
issues coming out of that exercise that
that you'd like to tell the committee in
terms of pointers
um only in the sense that
um we see a variety of practice we see a
good deal of adherence to the EF
um measures that that they think are of
critical importance we see the balance
that I've described between
uh you know specific targeted
interventions for individual pupils and
uh and for
um whole schools but we will take that
evidence and we will do what we've done
throughout this program which is you
know push back into the system where it
seems uh to have been uh most effective
if I may well one of the one of the
points that we are learning
all the time is just how much the um the
ambition of of uh School leaders using
eef evidence which is the gold standard
evidence how much does that have been
followed we now we have uh we see
evidence that there's 70 of school
leaders are are following uh the
evidence and one of the things I'm proud
to start with in terms of of uh of uh
what we've done over the time that I've
been here is the establishment of the
eef as as that gold standard and we
re-endowed the
um EF only last year for another 10
years that's made such a difference in
terms of the of your legacy I I'm I I do
regard that as part of my legacy and I'm
really really proud of the EFS uh we we
do like a little bit proud of their
public service thank you thank you Mr
General Lee um so over to Ann Marie
Morris MP thank you chair
um Miss Agland Hood
what work has been done to try and
compare how we have done in the UK as
compared to other countries
internationally similarly impacted by
covid the start points I think were
different but I'd be interested to
understand particularly given that
whether or not the processing systems
for example the tutoring that have been
used here were they mirrored abroad were
the things that we saw going on abroad
that we theirs are that's a good idea
and brought that in and has that given
us
um a comparatively better outcome or
Worse outcome I think right at the start
you said nobody was predicting to be
able to fully close the gap but
nonetheless how are we doing in terms of
getting there exactly how we get there
yes the Gap I was talking about was this
was the gap between disadvantages
overall
the so we look we look a lot at the
international levels and actually we
spent quite a lot of time and I might
bring Mr option who has our
International function in his um uh in
his command but um and actually very
early in the pandemic I spent quite a
lot of time talking to my counterparts
around the world about what they were
putting in place in order to make sure
exactly as you described that we weren't
missing things that people were doing it
it is slightly complicated because the
pandemic experiences around the world
were quite profoundly different
um so you see everything from so rather
than just one of the differences what
lessons did you learn so
there are some things we see so so
versions of the
um Recovery Premium in other words
additional money for schools to spend
kind of
basically perhaps not right that schools
needed money that's very common and we
saw a lot of that around the world um
tutoring approaches we have seen we've
actually had more people come to look at
what we're doing on that and take it so
that there's been learning that that way
more I would say than in the other
direction
um uh the the investment in teacher
training and development again is
something
um that we both see around the world and
that we have a lot of international
partners coming to
um uh talk to us about because of the
the work that we had already underway on
the early career framework and the
national professional qualifications
allowed us to go quite far and fast on
that and then you still see huge vet and
I mean again I was talking to Andre
Schleicher yesterday we also try and use
international comparative work to look
at differential experiences but again a
lot a lot of the sort of headline
conclusions are just that people were in
very different circumstances and
therefore have ended up in different
places yeah I I think it's fair to say
that we we learn we learn more about
um we learn more from other systems in
periods which are longer term and not in
not interpolated and crisis management
so you know on uh pedagogy and on
teacher training we learn a lot over a
long period from our partners we we host
each year here in education World Forum
which is one way in which we uh drive
that but we learned I think far more in
those circumstances than we have from
covert where circumstances are different
and as you say chair not everything that
was done was rocket science some of it
though some of it wasn't out at least
for decades
um given what you said that everyone's
starting a slightly different place
and I know it's difficult therefore to
compare are we doing better worse or on
par with the speed of trying to if you
like reduce that attainment Gap
Mr Archer I
I don't think we have very clear
comparisons
um I would say we are
um you know broadly comparable rather
than significantly ahead or
significantly behind some of this won't
we won't know really until we see the
impact on young people over the next
decade Pizza thank you Miss Blake
um thank you chair um I just wanted to
ask a few quick questions about the
summer school program and whether you
felt that the purpose and impact of
those um programs were what the DFE
anticipated
um so
and we've already had a little bit of an
exchange about the funding
um we didn't spend as much money
um
um as we had made available
um and that's partly because
um of you know an ongoing and dynamic um
period of disruption it's partly about
us announcing the the funding was
available close to the time and it's
partly about the way schools felt most
able to use and best able to use the uh
the money
um but
um 340 000
um children benefited in
2800 schools and in terms of
Effectiveness
um you know almost all
um those who you know who who expressed
of you said that that was effective in
improving transition from primary to
secondary I mean you would hope that
that was
um the case wouldn't you and about 73 so
three quarters said it was also
effective in
um improving well-being as part of that
transition so for that not at all in
significance indeed rather large group
of children I think um the summer school
program did what we had hoped and
intended it would do
you think if you were to do this again
you might not give the money directly to
schools but potentially
a secondary provider
um I mean I'm my my principle in in in
most things is that is that schools are
the is the place and
um are the you know the people who are
best able to determine what is best for
their
um pupils I think you need to be
um really clear don't you about who
those providers might be and who those
local Partnerships uh might be and we do
rely
um in a number of ways on you know
strong local Partnerships to provide
um provision in partnership with schools
and but I'm not sure that I think that
taking away
um the funding or the you know the means
to direct that funding is the way to
Best Target pupil needs and
I think part of the purpose of the
summer school program was that focus on
transition and recognizing that that
there'd be particular challenges in for
people to missed out on the
opportunities that they typically have
to kind of visit Schools they're going
into in the term beforehand and so on
and I think with that transition aiming
view it would have been odd not to give
the money to schools because it's the
school who can best support transition
into itself if that makes sense I think
it's worth remembering we were doing
other things as well so the holiday
activities and food program for example
which provides activity support and and
good quality food for children's
backgrounds in the summer holidays I
think
in terms of the kind of long-term aim to
address the the summer learning loss
we've typically see more acutely among
disadvantaged peoples those kinds of
programs that make sure children are
able to have the opportunity to be
engaged in really good quality and
purposeful activity over the summer in
the way that their more advantaged
counterparts may take for granted also
have a really important role to play but
the summer schools particularly about
the transition and therefore I think
made sense to give money School speaking
given transition is an issue every year
um and that was quite an impressive
percentage you gave then in your answer
Mr Archer do you think that this is
something DFE would consider going
forward
um
I mean we were in a very particular
situation where children had missed out
on the experiences that would normally
lead them up to and into that transition
we had a you know a piece of funding
which was
um specifically for that purpose so I
don't think we would be replicating
exactly the same thing and and and you
know as with all these sort of these
future funding available conversations
and that's very much a matter for um the
next spending review yeah absolutely and
then you won't be here to worry about
that at that point you could have just
said yes
but clearly you're still a professional
civil civil rights here Ms Blake any
last Quick okay we're going to turn that
back to Jeffrey Clifton several quick
questions with with relevant short
answers please because time is moving on
given that exchange
um firstly you are to be congratulated
as a department I think by the speed
with which you actually did intervene
with the national Beauty program but
given that exchange why did you think uh
that actually you're going to best be
able to deliver this National tutor
training program centrally through
ramstat rather than uh delivered by
schools obviously the teachers know best
what is best for their peoples and
children and indeed who are the
disadvantaged ones and who needs it most
why did you ever think it was right to
deliver it centrally
so I mean my my view is that there are
three ways in which schools can best
engage tutors and I think all three of
them are important and maybe May benefit
different pupils differentially now
those are using existing tutoring
organizations and obviously there is you
know an existing tutoring Market outside
of the
um the national tutoring program the
second is bringing in new and
um trained and dedicated um
um people to do tutoring the third is
using
um your own staff and local Partners to
um deliver tutoring and we began with
the areas which most obviously
put in additional resource and Drew on
uh existing capacity and I think we did
that successfully
um um you know in both the first and
notwithstanding some of the difficulties
with Randstad performance the second
year we provided a great deal of support
to schools through tutoring
organizations and through what we called
academic mentors the centrally appointed
and then you know pushed out to schools
additional resource and I think that
worked well and we learned through the
program
um as you would you would hope we would
um firstly that some pupils did not
benefit from that and the most obvious
example of that perhaps is there's a lot
of people's special educational needs
felt the need you know were better being
tutored by people they knew and people
in schools that's you know that's sort
of one
um particular example but many other
examples about how we're tutoring from
within the school was better so we put
alongside
um those other two methods a
um a school more directly school-led
approach that approach
more popular significantly more popular
so we switched our
means of funding
um so that it was much more school-led
learning from the previous point but
still hoping and indeed I think the fact
is that schools are still using those
three methods and we have
um you know organizations who support
schools with quality assurance with
training so that whatever route
um tutoring is delivered by is delivered
at really good quality so you know I I
think we've got benefits out of all
three of those routes and we've shifted
given the evidence in front of us as
much of the evidence in front of us
though is very much focused on the
school-led tutoring bits of Jeff
frequency
so um
Mr Archer why have 13 of schools Not
Taken part at all in the National
teaching Supreme program
um but that I mean that remains I think
um for me at least the biggest
um disappointment in the program
um I think schools will have you know a
range of different reasons for why
um they engage some of them will be
about their view of the value of
tutoring some of it will be about the
um process of engaging people to do
um tutoring but what um I can
um assure the committee is that we have
put a good deal of resource and continue
to put a good deal of resource into
persuading those schools of the benefits
of uh tutoring and seeking to reduce
that number both directly through you
know through phone calls and other
contacts and through identifying what
has worked really well and looking to
use that to engage a wider a wider group
of schools so this is a little worrying
going forward but can I move to a
slightly different issue Williamston
this is was raised to us by a number of
colleagues but um Paul Hal MP the Member
of Parliament for Sedgefield in
particular
um he says my understanding from action
tutoring is the tutor subsidy is set to
fall to 25 this year from its current
rate of 60 given the challenges facing
many schools action tutoring has said
this may put significant pressure on
their activities and this is the worry
is it not
um that that schools are increa if we
increasingly being the plans are there
to carry on the national tutor training
program but schools are increasingly
being asked to do it out of their own
budget now I know from my own
constituency schools that they are
having great difficulties meeting their
budget all the other things they've got
to do like mental health we've discussed
all of that Recruitment and so on how
are they going to actually do this
so I mean the first thing says we've
always been clear that the program would
um taper
um in
um its share of the subsidy and has
already begun that that tapering process
um I also think that if you want as we
do
tutoring to be a normal and embedded
part of the school system then
it has to be funded through the normal
school funding process and Our intention
is was both to support in a particularly
difficult period post covert but also to
um sell the benefits to of tutoring to
those schools who hadn't previously used
it and
um to show clearly um the way in which
that
picked up on narrowing the disadvantage
Gap in particular going forward and you
know with the additional funding which
has gone into the main School budgets
this year and we do expect to see you
know schools increasingly using their
mainstream funding and making it
sustainable I understand that that your
wish to put it through the main scheme
of school funding and that's fine if you
actually do it but if they don't have
any actual extra funding given them
pressures on their budgets already what
it effectively will mean is that this
National tutor training program will
start the weather on the vine and given
the the the the catch up that is
obviously still needed particularly in
disadvantaged children
um surely this would be would not be the
right thing to do well except except
that
um what I think the program has shown
thus far is the value of tutoring as a
specific intervention and one that you
would therefore want schools to use
their
um you know existing budgets
misunderstood my question Jeffrey I was
not in any way questioning the value of
the national tutor training program we
all admit that it's it's had huge value
and still could have huge value but if
it isn't funded with the secondhood
perhaps this is a question for you
because this is a high level question on
funding if unless the schools are funded
specifically for it extra funding from
what they're getting now it is
inevitably gained with it on the vine
and wouldn't that be the wrong thing to
do given the benefits we've already seen
evidence is really clear on this from
various parties I
think I think
I think first is do we at some point
want to mainstream this into core
schools budgets and if we wanted to be a
core feature in the system we remember
us do that the second thing is do you do
you sort of almost then sort of soft
ring fence a chunk of money and say this
is for that and it's going to school's
budgets and we tend to try not to do
that because actually what we want is
because making good allocative choices
in their budgets what we do want is
schools to be sufficiently funded to do
all the things they need to do for their
pupils we put an extra 2 billion into
the system in the Autumn statement this
year school funding overall this year is
therefore going up by something of the
order of four billion
um and the pupil premium is there
specifically for interventions targeted
at individual pupils one of the things
we want to do through National teaching
program is demonstrate the value so
people can think about the the choices
they make with the money they've got and
then the third point is about
the taper of the subsidy and whether or
not moving from 60 to 25 in a single
year is is too big a drop in order to
achieve that end and the committee made
a recommended the Nea report made a
recommendation that we should model the
impact of that shift in the subsidy and
we accepted that recommendation we think
it's really important that we do so it
is something that we have been
kind of we've had an eye on because it
clearly is a significant drop in the
level of subsidy and that is an action
we'll be taking uh
um And discussing with our friends on
the treasury I hear what you're saying
good and and and and I accept those
extra resources going into schools but
will you undertake today to keep
monitoring this and if there is a
significant drop off in tutor training
um then you will look at this whole
issue of funding again and see what more
needs to be done that's very very
helpful
um just one final point on this
um this is again from Paul Howell he
says he understood that the ntp
originally had targets of 65 pupil
premium targets but this has been
removed
yeah I mean this this again would seem
to indicate that we're lessening the
importance of um people premium
those disadvantaged children uh yeah
it's the again we we did touch on this
briefly early yes we did so the the the
target we set was when we had a national
program for for randstadt we thought
that was important when we had a single
National program delivering that we
thought they thought about how they were
targeting to schools what we now what we
now do is we allocate the funding to
schools based on whether or not on the
number of people premium pupils they
have so we're achieving the same end
through different means
thank you I mean but the evidence on on
the tutoring and the budget pressures I
mean just uh I mean the missing is an
example
um
we're basically basically people saying
they can't I've got several job
vacancies to support of they can't
recruit so even if they've got money to
spend on tutoring they're finding it
hard to recruit people on that but let
alone the core stuff so I think that the
basic funding issues in schools are the
big is one of the big messages that came
through in evidence and from a range as
I say Witnesses and members of
parliament
um over to Olivia Blake MP um thank you
just two questions on
um kind of spread and specific support
what extra support are you giving to
children in the north of England given
the greater learning loss and Mr McAuley
and
the very
um
tilting of all of all the funding that
we've been talking about
um
by disadvantage means that actually it
is for it it reaches and let's focus
those with the those schools and indeed
those areas with with the greatest
proportions of of the disadvantaged uh
pupils so that's not necessarily
specifically the north but actually in
terms of the way in which uh the the uh
the distribution of disadvantaged people
it means that it it does it does do that
and at every level so for instance even
in the in the the um uh the core school
funding
um uh system uh we have uh reviewed the
uh the the factors and the national
funding formula every every every year
since its introduction and this year
um it has been it's the biggest
proportion of of
um of uh of funding going into
disadvantage which is has meant that the
further distribution of of
orienteering of funding benefits the uh
the north more more than in the previous
iterations the funding formula so
there's nothing specific in this
um well
um I would draw attention to the to the
uh education investment
um uh uh area so it was a key part of
the school's white white paper
um uh so developed alongside of our our
work around the uh from education uh
recovery and those education investment
areas are and have a a sort of full
representation in the in the uh in the
uh the north of England and it's in
those areas that we're sort of targeting
the uh the uh our sort of key action on
school Improvement for instance it's in
those areas where we have the targeting
in particular the
um the teacher recruitment uh premium
that and citizen mentioned a little a
Gophers especially for those shortage
subjects such as maths physics and uh
and and and Computing and in addition to
uh to to to to those areas we've got uh
to that to those activities we've got
additional funding around some of the
bespoke was a partnership
activities so
um the the the
um identification of those areas and the
and the uh additional support going into
those areas uh does does um benefit
um north of England and just very
quickly on on maths
um given the Ambitions of number 10 What
specifically is going into people's
um catch-up in maths yes well maths of
fundamentally extensive
um uh uh uh sort of of of responses I
just highlight um how much maths is a
key part in the math tuition is a key
part of the national tutoring
um uh uh program if you look down the
the range of of tutors and Sport matters
is is is by far this of the um one of
the predominant uses of the national
tutoring program I'd highlight the um
further extension of the maths hubs now
reaching
um
a very substantial numbers of schools
with the um the the
um uh extension of our maths Mastery
approaches based on the very best
evidence from Shanghai in particular
um which has I think been one of the
fundamental uh changes in the way in
which we teach maths in this country on
the benefit of that I'd highlight
um the
um uh the accelerator fund which is part
of the uh of the recovery package and
again
um the the demonstration of effective
um uh uh sort of maths uh teaching uh
through the through the accelerator fund
particularly in mastering number which
has been a key part of the maths hubs
activities and and outside the school
program actually into 16 to 19 uh uh
again key part of the education recovery
area and I think given the the future
focus and come into future focus on on
maths you can uh we are working even
even more on on on on on developing
those approaches great thank you for
that
um just to move on quickly
time and without Milestones how are you
going to track your um that you're going
to meet your attainment
targets for 2020 2013 even amps out in
the white paper for schools
Limited
and uh working for your last few weeks
I I point to a number of of things first
of all we um we set out
um uh
um the submetrics and our measures in
our in our Department's uh uh
operational
um plan that we publish
um uh clearly the uh the annual
um uh
um results for more and our tests and
our GCSE is also fundamentals of moments
of of
um of setting uh the progress levels and
um
the long-term mission of the schools
might paper and obviously invites a um a
recognition that that of the importance
of of uh um setting uh progress measures
we didn't do that in the schools by
white paper we are looking
um to do that and
especially in in uh so our plans for uh
for uh further reinforcing and
implementing the schools by paper
measures and I I expect to be able to
share with the
um the wider world and indeed possibly
even this committee um a a
um uh plans for uh Primary in the uh
within the next couple of months
I mean that would be very helpful that
kind of links to my next question which
is how will you keep Parliament updated
um on on progress towards the Ambitions
of the white paper targets
yeah
yes I mean I think I I I think Mr
McCauley's covered quite quite a lot of
that so I mean we we we set those
ambitious Targets in the school's white
paper at both key stage two and Q stage
four but every year in our outcome
delivery plan we publish actually a
wider range of metrics at both Key Stage
2 and Q stage four we also published the
results of the key stage one
um test the phonics reading check
multiplications table check and so on
and we use all of those to hold
ourselves to account and we expect other
people to use them to hold us to account
for Progress okay
um thank you I've just got a question
about the performance and risk committee
and how often will they be scrutinizing
the education recovery program
so our performance we we have
um uh boards for each of the three main
pieces of the department for skills
schools and families and the Schools
board will look at this meets monthly
and will I mean in effect look at this
every month because it because the
business of Education recovery is so
closely intertwined with the core
business of the Schools board which is
the progress that children are making in
schools so the Schools board will look
at it essentially every month the
performance and risk committee
uh as I hope you would expect takes a
risk-based approach to what it looks at
and focuses on making sure it's covered
our top risks in rotation so it's a bit
difficult to predict exactly how often
it would take this as a kind of core
substantive item but it'd look across
the performance of the whole department
in every meeting so it does that
quarterly
and back to Mr McAuley I guess kind of
be interesting to know what measures you
would be reporting back to that
committee and the performance and risk
committee to show impact and and that
things are working or not
um and certainly against the
um
some of the key Imports we haven't at
the beginning of this discussion we we
we talked about this of teacher quality
um uh improvements so that at the moment
is mostly important inputs how many how
many teachers how many
um uh uh whether the the courses have
been completed so reporting on that uh
regularly but but but increasingly now
that the accountability
um system and testing and and and
is is back on stream obviously having
that as a as a as a a regular piece
phonic screening check and and
multiplication table check are a number
of the other in inputs and the Neo in
its recommendations and
encourage the further development of
longitudinal studies I that's a very
good recommendation that we've had some
of that uh in the past and we've
committed to um to add to investigate
how we do that and and I would love to
add that to the suite of of information
and reporting that that we add to make
sure that we're on track so that's
something as a result of the Neo report
that we we've committed to do it's
reassurance here and links to my next
question which is in an Ideal World what
data points would you um like to have at
your disposal in that Ideal World you'd
certainly have some of that that we
don't have at the moment we we had more
of that uh through very very specific
research pieces that we'd had during the
during covid working with organizations
such as the educational policy
institutes
um uh and I think that is um as the Nao
report uh identified we can do better by
by
turning and and expanding on on that
experience and that's that's something
where where we've committed to do I mean
I'm heartened about the value of
longitudinal study because that's
important but I'm quite concerned in in
all what we've been hearing today that
we've got a very urgent situation right
now that was predictable during covid
that we're going to have a problem and
yet there's going to be cohorts that
will never get the benefit
um as we've heard from evidence and
we've had to leave from you of of some
of these supports or not enough well 30
only 35 of schools taking up some of the
programs
um schools finding it struggle to pay
for others cohorts going through we're
going to have the level of support
because I identified exam pupils quite
rightly on one level as either we're a
cohort that will lose out
I mean I I think it's important to say
that I mean the first the first
announcements around investments in
education recovery were made in June
2020 so that's pretty early in the
pandemic I'm not suggesting that the
ones
and it's it's not gonna ever be enough
is it no no I mean I think that is true
but but I do think it's worth it is
worth again there's a bit of there's a
bit of thanks to those in the system
who've made this possible but the the
longitudes actually had during the
pandemic showed that I mean particularly
in primary by Autumn 2021
um uh something like two-thirds of the
learning lost by Spring 2021 and primary
Reading had been caught up in about half
the learning lost in primary maths now
that is quite a that's quite rapid and
quite a significant achievement the
challenge is always that the first bit
so there's this very typical pattern
that the first bit of recovery is
quicker than it slows so there's
something about continuing that
investment but I think the the reach of
the programs
has been something we've been really
trying to to focus on and although
Graham is ruthlessly chasing down the 13
of schools that haven't taken part in
the National teaching program it does
leave the vast majority of schools in
the country having but I think I mean
the lessons come over there from all the
evidence we've seen and for a previous
work we've done that if you haven't got
qualified teachers in the classroom so
you can't recruit you can't recruit
teaching assistants you can't pay for
teaching assistance then that will have
a break on children's ongoing attainment
and that in catch-up is a very Wicked
issue Mr Kelly is not doing that and the
you know we we know that the single
biggest contributor to children's
education is a great teacher which is
why so much the Investments has gone
into
um uh into teacher education and we and
we completely appreciate the chances of
recruitment from attention it probably
is worth saying we do have more teachers
about 24 000 more teachers in the system
than we had in
2010 and the largest number of teachers
across the school system that we've ever
had so we there are challenges and there
are there are challenges there are
particular challenges in recruiting to
particular subjects but we have we have
seen a a really significant growth in
the overall teacher work for me
certainly in London you know people
people tell you I mean you treat them
their heads tell you teacher leaves and
very often it's a non-specialist and
children are very aware when a
non-specialist is teaching them I'm
surprised how sad well not strike us
that's a bit of patronizing for teenage
I don't mean it but teenagers are very
innate to having a non-specialist
teacher on which subject so Jeffrey
Clifton Brown a very um quick question
to you Mr McConnell
um um given that the schools required
for the tutoring program are different
from a general teaching skills one
you're dealing with a class of 20 to 30
pupils the other you might be dealing on
a one-to-one basis or at least on a very
small group
if we're not to see this uh ntp Wither
on the vine which is I'm really
concerned about how are we going to
create a sustainable Market in tuition
and how are you going to assist teachers
with that different skill set
and uh quality is is the is the
watchword and and so
um and it is not just therefore about
about finding additional um tutors but
it's um through the tuition partner vote
important though that is
um uh but also about the extent to which
are the effective practice and the ever
the use of the evidence about what how
effective tuition is delivered uh means
that that could that could be the the
most fundamentals of legacy of of the
work that we've done so far and the way
in which embeds tutoring uh into the
system uh for good so I particularly
point to
um uh this of the the training that is
um that goes into all ass or limbs of
the national tutoring program
um uh the training this is what we have
that quality assurance I've ever seen by
uh one of our um uh contractual Partners
uh EDT
um
but then underpinned by the uh this by
the uh the research and the best
practice uh we talked about that earlier
uh that um demonstrated by the eef and
uh nfer
um implementation
um uh evidence and research so that that
for me is is as important part of the
sort of
um uh this of having a
um a legacy of of tutoring opponent of
the system as it is about
um identifying additional organizations
or additional tutors I'll just say one
more thing about the training so we've
had about 20 000 people go through that
dedicated training we initially said
that you must be trained if you were
going to do tutoring as a teaching
assistant in a school context but you
didn't have to be trained if you were
already a qualified teacher because we
thought that's right the right amount
interestingly actually most schools have
put their qualified teachers through the
training as well and the feedback on the
training has been extremely positive
from both qualified teachers and
teaching assistants so there's a there's
a there's a long-term Legacy of having
skilled more people in schools up to
deliver that one-to-one and small group
tutoring effect because as you say the
skills are different from whole class
teachers do the training up of teaching
assistants again I've seen so many
potential uh exciting legacies of the of
the work that we're doing and uh the the
um the having fundamentals of training
um uh offer and development for for the
teachers and that's what's so so so and
that's going to be an ongoing program
okay thank you Jeffrey not any analysis
of about twenty thousand how and what
what percentage of it is uh teachers and
teaching assistants from the individual
schools and what percentage of it is
teachers and other well-qualified people
from outside the schools because
presumably this is going to be delivered
by not just teachers in the schools it's
going to be delivered by Outsiders as
well it is and I don't have those
figures as well we'll look to see
whether we can provide the the uh more
specific of those figures but you're
absolutely right that the typical
um uh to the um School school-led
tuition is is not just
um looking at teachers and teaching
systems but also retired teachers and
and in in some instances uh parents
engage with the schools
and thank you
um Miss Auckland hotel and when will we
know whether the schemes for Education
recovery and the extra funding has
delivered value for money
so
um I think we'll know different things
about different parts of the program at
different times so we've got evaluation
wrapped around every element of the
program
um and we're putting those out as as we
have them so the evaluation we put out
on the summer schools program which were
created from is already out there for
example there's continuing evaluation of
the um uh of the national teaching
program but I think I think there are
lots of extremely positive signs
including actually in the fact that
we've delivered the amount of tutoring
we said we wanted to deliver at somewhat
lower cost than we initially thought it
might take so I I think
um I suspect this will be an ongoing uh
exploration between us and the National
Audit office but we continue we will
continue to put as much evidence out
about the value for money of the work
that we're doing as we can as quickly as
we have it and that final one from me a
Chad Mr Archer what lessons have you
learned from the first two years that
you're going to apply to the next two
years or that not you necessarily but
you well exactly
people should
and so for me it's about
um the the power of data to help you
target effectively to those
um pupils and places that need it most
um and those are powerful
um thing too about uh trusting schools
and teachers uh and the great work that
they do
um to Drive
um the the narrow you know the sharp
targeting on those peoples who need it
most so targeting in the broad and then
targeting in the narrow and trusting
schools and schools and teachers to do a
really good job as they do I think
that's a wonderful note to finish on
because I think we would all say Amen to
that oh and so Jeffrey's
I will I will go away from this session
um still quizzical if I if I don't ask
this question and it's it's it's
slightly different question but what
embedded lessons have we learned from
the pandemic uh in terms of remote
learning and roll out of the computer
program and so on there must be some
very useful lessons that we've learned
what are they yes and I might bring
others in on this as well so I think we
I think we've learned that remote
learning is not a good substitute for a
teacher I think quite a lot of us
probably thought that to start off with
but there was quite a lot of kind of
in The Ether about whether or not you
were effectively indicated that some
people's founded a bit easier to speak
online
true but I think so I just focus your
question because it may be that some of
this remote learning is useful in
addition to yes class teaching
particularly for things like homework
yeah so that's where what I was going to
go on and say actually so I think we've
learned a lot about using Technologies
to support homework I think we've
learned actually quite a lot about using
technology to support teachers in how
they deliver learning so there were some
things that where teachers were using
um
more
um edtech packages alongside the remote
learning that allowed them it actually
goes back to grounds point about
targeting to be able to see and
understand the patterns of attainment
among their pupils more clearly and
actually there's a program of work we're
now doing in the department we've added
education technology more clearly to the
eef's remittus part of its endowment and
and we've got some work going on uh um
sort of following on from the Legacy
edtech demonstrator partners and some of
the other things we do to look at
exactly those lessons that have been
learned not just about remote learning
but about the use of technology in
schools during the pandemic or widely
plus of course remote parents evening
which is everybody's favorite thing okay
thank you very much thank you very much
Nick and I thank you all for your time
the transcript we off on the website and
corrected in the next couple of days and
again thanks to Mr McCully and Mr Archer
for their Decades of service in the
department for Education we hope you
have a happy retirement order